prune devenez merci michel l'anc
ouais
alors comment elle est belle c'est vrai
on peut pas dire le contraire en faisant
observer tous les deux vous avez des
supers dieu tout à michel peut pas dire
des trucs comme ça gratuit tu me dises à
moi forcément après je vais avoir envie
qui se passe quelque chose entre nous
mais moi je sais ça y est depuis
longtemps cherché à chaque fois qu'on se
voit sur un plateau de télé michèle
laroque
on se dit qu'on va se revoir sans les
caméras après toi tu pars los angeles
moi je fais toutes mes émissions se voit
pas alors si on n'était pas à la télé tu
me dirais tu où tu me direz vous bon bah
je te dis tu es ce que si on n'était pas
à la télé tu serais aussi heureuse de
voir que ce soir c'est déjà arrivé
ouais ouais mais pas assez je trouve est
ce que tu te serais fait aussi belle si
on n'était pas la télé pour m'avoir mais
j'ai toujours vu moi aussi
resplendissante c'est le soleil
je n'étais pas raté le titre serait
laisser faire par exemple on fait quoi
si on était pas là d on irait boire un
verre on est des rêves inverse tuque des
planes endroit super voila voila de la
bouteille tfou toi tu crois que tu as dû
faire à l'envers avec connais par coeur
ça fait trente neuf ans tu fais ce
métier c'est plus moi michel g merdier
sur scène je vais les prendre en
attendant je suis désolé je voulais pas
dire ça est-ce que sur les quais pas la
télé michel tu me dirait vraiment ce que
tu penses de moi oui moi je connais un
thierry ardisson que j'adore parce qu'on
est double ouais et que et que et avec
beaucoup de sensibilité gentillesse et
d'intelligence et je pense et qui a un
autre et hardy sont pas bons on connaît
pas que j'aie jamais rencontré vraiment
dont parfois on parle parfois et
j'espère que celui que je connais va
complètement changer voilà jacquin
thierry ardisson ce n'était pas la télé
je pourrais te pour être dragués toi tu
es marié tu sais moi je suis sérieuse
alors si on était paraît-il et on
parlerait de ton actu tu crois non on
n'en parlerait pas en fait ce n'était
pas ça n'était pas été on va en parler
parce qu'on annonçait ce que tu
t'intéresses à tout ce que je fais tu me
donnerait alors non j'aime bien sûr en
arrivant je pense que je te demanderai
de trois questions
on me donnait une con je crois alex
olive
je crois que les mecs ils ont décidé de
me question est ce que ça va intéresser
le public mon spectacle
ouais tu vas voir qu'après cette
émission décor il va intéresser le plus
ailleurs
jamel c'est le toucher si tu veux pas
moi non mais non nettoie fait comme si
de rien n'était vous continuez vos
émissions
allez-y voir on y va on a un problème il
n'a pas un caméra wi 80 je pense que ma
veste et qu'il l'a pas fait nous partons
sur l'iran bien il revient à tanit et
l'oeil de triche tag c'est le mec de
blondie tu sais moi je suis désolé s'est
quittés potes qui sont avec toi là dédé
est repris de justesse et socialement
alors michel tu vas me chan qui va
tourner un peu d'albi endormi avec
d'armand dutronc dany boon a exactement
je crois qu'on va beaucoup s'amuser et
dany boon tu l'as tu l'as vu ces
temps-ci non la dernière fois que je les
ai vus j'ai pas vu sa pièce mais je vais
y aller mais alors parce qu'il était en
vacances à megève il a aidé voilà il
avait l'air en forme et j'ai remis de sa
séparation d'avec judith parce qu'elle
était la semaine dernière bell a l'air
de s'être bien remise mais je pensais
séparation lieu sous sol et je crois en
l'homme
une même thierry à madame catherine me
demande si on peut aller chercher une
baisse de secours chez moi catherine
mais si je donne le code comme je fais
une autre émission chez moi la note
catherine c'est mort c'est dommage que
philippe de gaulle soit parti le malade
a honoré qui fait faire philippe de
gaulle nous ce racket canada oui c'est
sûr bien donc
judith godrèche et hey lalala semaine la
semaine dernière elle avait l'air
d'avoir assez bien appris sa séparation
d'avec dany boon sasa allen en étant
mieux oui dany ça va aussi
j'ai l'impression les robes à s'en faire
pour un non alors il ya aussi un coffret
qui va sortir avec ils s'aiment ils se
sentent si me voilà avec pierre patry se
fait engueuler non mais ça me met km
avec cameron
oui quand bien même après qu'il sort
avec qu'ils s'aiment ils se sont
eux-mêmes
voilà c'est ça ouais la saga complète tu
penses tu fais quoi michel quand tu pars
tout le temps à los angeles comme ça
alors moi je prépare un film j'ai acheté
les droits d'un livre qui s'appelle
pitch et caroline bong rome je le
connais voilà bien sûr et on voudrait
faire un film inspiré de ce livre tu vas
faire un film sauvez le pitch peut-être
alors tu vas venir le pitch est ici un
max obligatoire oui alors je n'étais pas
la télé ce que je pourrais couper les
moments où j'ai l'air con quand je te
regarde comme ça jamais l'air con c'est
vrai oui c'est une idée que tu te fais
tu m'impressionnes ce n'était pas la
télé tu dirais quoi du décor de cette
émission
franchement il ya un truc que j'aime
beaucoup c'est la veste mais vraiment
pas je suis sincère je trouve que kate
sept ans
non un petit truc si je manque un petit
truc je vais la signer way up
ouais
sur gaza
un cartel est ce que va devenir la
léguer sa part comment sur la peau ça
paraît
soit que là je suis comme ça pour un
long moment ce qu'on peut faire mal et
les uns des lingettes
mais l'os est là revient avec des
lingettes valérie je continue interview
de madame laroque
je termine ici alors ce n'était pas la
télé tu aurais quoi comme problème à me
raconter je sais pas ce qu'il ya eu dans
le ciel les armes et caetera que les
gens qui étaient un peu fragiles sont
allées très très très mal ouais et
j'avais plein de coups de fil de gens
qui allaient mal et ça m'a vraiment
inquiété voilà c'est ça les problèmes en
ce moment d'essayer de jean phlippe un
peu en ce moment c'est la période de
l'année sinon messi n'est pas comme s'il
était chez huawei
ouais et puis comme je suis maintenant
entre les deux c'est quand je reviens je
sens plus ces choses parce que j'ai pas
subi tu vois toutes les pressions ici et
je trouve que parfois c'est très lourd
et je trouve que les gens sont plus clip
et en france aux états unis en france
c'est différent ils sont très fines a
pas d'accord avec vous je chante mais à
cause de bouche médecine on mettait les
gens n'ont plus le moral
il ya eu quelque chose ou et de deux je
trouve un truc les gens ont pu la pêche
non qu'est ce qui se passe là bas
iron man repas catherine dit miley dans
la loge vip d'accord ok je viens
d'assister une chose extraordinaire ici
j'espère que t'as pas mis un costume
neuf non c'est oui mais je sais qu'on
n'écoute pas à mourir un jouet thierry
acquérir total chic type toi c'est pas
voir
seul
il s'est enfui il s'est enfui à le janet
tiens si quelqu'un pouvait maîtriser
jamel debbouze
personne n'a à gilles questions à poser
à thierry thierry tu m'entends je
t'entends djamel comment tu peux mettre
des photos pareil sérieux quoi tu y as
mais david valider la cua rien mauvaise
mise sur cette photo mais c'est le style
de la photo djamel trop la ola le sol
t'apprendra à dire que mon spectacle
n'est pas intéressante du fonds
alors si on n'était pas la télévision
même s'ils n'étaient pas la télévision
est ce que tu me parlerait quand même de
gerpinnes teurs ben ouais ouais c'est
bien ouais c'est bien et bien content
pour lui parce que c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de talent et
j'adore le spectacle qui fait les gens
mais ce martèlement et voilà quoi c'est
sait quelque chose
il a été longtemps un to lose it arrivée
à paris là tout ça leur lui a pas encore
la pression ait eu l'impression qu'il
vous a donné exactement il y croit
vraiment et je trouve que c'est bien et
alors il est venu ici nous parler de son
nouveau spectacle qui s'appelle on tire
bien sûr les lapins au théâtre fontaine
tu l'as vu évidemment rien ça fait
marrer et ma fille l'adorent et ma mère
l'a d'or tu vois c'est un peu tout
génération doit bientôt mais enfin super
bien j'ai en pin teurs on tire bien sûr
les lapins